si bon soir voici les titres de ce
journal en albanie les bâtiments de la
télévision et du parlement à tirana la
capitale occupée manu militari par des
opposants au gouvernement
surconsommation de médicaments pour les
personnes de plus de 70 ans attention
trop de médicaments peuvent entraîner
des accidents graves l'immigration
clandestine à marseille des mineurs
venues illégalement france sont pris en
charge pour éviter des dérives barbara
écrivait ses mémoires mémoires
interrompu et publiée aujourd'hui sur sa
vie et son besoin de chanter ce qui
s'est passé ce matin tirana la capitale
albanaise a toutes les apparences d'un
coup d'état
des hommes armés partisans de
l'ex-président berisha ont pris le
contrôle des bâtiments de la télévision
d'état puis de ceux du parlement trois
manifestants ont été tués et 14 blessés
dans les affrontements avec les forces
de l'ordre cette situation
insurrectionnelle fait suite à
l'assassinât d'un député d'opposition
mais le premier ministre albanais
monsieur fatos nano n'a pas l'intention
de démissionner commentaires thierry
thulliez à tirana les obsèques du député
d'opposition tuée samedi total émeutes
des milliers manifestants sont dans la
rue exigeant la démission du
gouvernement
juchés sur un char dont qui se sont
emparés d'une caserne ils ont investi la
télévision c'était monsieur nous arrêter
les vaches duncan hector charland à
l'origine de ces émeutes
un meurtre considéré ici comme un
assassinat politique
la victime hazem ajdari
bras droit de l'ancien président sali
berisha
assem ajdari a été tué par des officiers
de police accuse berisha sur ordre de
fatos nano l'actuel premier lieu hier
sur la place centrale de tirana la foule
était venue rendre un dernier hommage au
député d'opposition assassiner l'ancien
président venu réconforter la famille et
dis-je maintenant la démission pour
limite fatos nano l'ex communiste
rebaptisé socialiste vainqueur des
élections besoin 97
les élections qui avait mis un terme à
une guerre civile qui avait fait deux
morts et provoqué l'évacuation des
ressortissants étrangers les casernes
avaient alors été pillé hier parmi les
manifestants il y avait un homme armes
bilan provisoire de ces émeutes trois
tués et 14 blessés
ce soir la police albanaise affirment
avoir repris le contrôle des sièges du
gouvernement du parlement et de la
télévision
ce qui ne suffit pas à rassurer
complètement les habitants aux etats
unis le rapport de force entre les
autorités de la maison blanche d'une
part le congrès des parlementaires et la
presse d'autre part ne semble pas
modifier fondamentalement l'opinion des
citoyens américains sur leur président
malgré les révélations du rapport
kenneth starr sur la sphère levinsky la
procédure de censure parlementaire si
elle va jusqu'à son terme ne demandera
plusieurs semaines et pour l'instant
bill clinton entend montrer qu'il
continue à gérer les affaires
américaines malgré de nouvelles
révélations à washington commentaires
philippe gassot après un dimanche passé
à la maison blanche sans témoin sans
médias la première image du président
cette semaine donnent le ton c'est celle
d'un homme qui prend à bras le corps les
dossiers importants
c'est à présent l'attitude que va
adopter bill clinton
les regrets les excuses c'est fini selon
l'équipe le défenseur est suffisamment
performante pour qu'il passe à autre
chose
aujourd'hui à new york il s'agit du rôle
de l'économie américaine dans le monde
ce matin au congrès juste avant
l'ouverture de la session les questions
libres portait bien entendu sur la
procédure éventuelle de destitution vous
êtes en train de me dire que les membres
de la chambre ne pourront pas statué sur
le rapport star avant la fin des travaux
de la commission judiciaire
vous avez raison
les parlementaires vont devoir attendre
peut-être plusieurs semaines car le
travail est énorme
le président a déjà son idée mais ce
n'est pas le cas pour tous les membres
de la commission judiciaire
pensez vous qu'il y assez de preuves
pour aller plus loin dans le processus
d'accusation je dois dire que oui mais
je veux entendre chaque membre du comité
nous allons exiger dans les semaines qui
viennent nous allons faire un travail
qui ne sera pas partisan
lorsque la commission aura examiné le
rapport il sera si les charges sont
jugées suffisantes transmis à la chambre
des représentants et si elle arrive aux
mêmes conclusions
ce sera aux sénateurs de juger le
président des états unis à la majorité
des deux tiers
chaque jour un témoignage un document ou
autres sont présentés au public le
dernier en date c'est un film vidéo non
signes qui laissent un vilain goût une
étrange jeune femme tamponne l'ajout du
président
elle restera la dernière quand le gros
des joggeurs sortira par la porte
principale le président conduire à la
jeune femme ou dans l'antichambre ou
monica avait ses habitudes
comprenne qui pourra ce document prouve
à l'évidence que le président américain
est toujours dans le collimateur d'une
partie de l'opinion
ce genre de taxe il y en aura d'autres
car pour les détracteurs de bill clinton
ce qu'il ne faut pas c'est laisser le
pays oubliez voir passer l'épongé vu de
pareil comportement de la presse
américaine est pour le moins surprenant
des dizaines de journaux américains ont
déjà demandé la démission du président
bill clinton
nous avons choisi de nous rendre à
washington dans les locaux de la
télévision civi est l'une des 3 plus
grandes rédactions nationales aux états
unis les moyens humains et matériels
mobilisés pour traiter cette affaire
clinton lewinsky sont démesurés
reportage maryse burgot et christophe
vignal
cette femme est ce matin extrêmement
pressés responsable du bureau de la
chaîne cbs à washington elle rentre en
conférence de rédaction
principal sujet du jour la suite de la
sphère clinton lewinsky
cet homme énumère le nombre de
reportages en cours de fabrication pour
le grand journal du soir 85 journalistes
et équipes sont mobilisées selon
jeannette lacenaire l'importance de
cette affaire nécessite une telle
mobilisation
avec louis assis bies nous avons essayé
d'être juste nous n'avons pas détaillé
les côtés salage du rapport
mais cet homme est le président des
états unis il devrait avoir plus de
jugement et nous pensons que les
américains doivent être courant de tout
ce qu'il a fait la rédaction de six
pièces comme toutes les autres grandes
chaînes de télévision est ainsi
mobilisés depuis huit mois
émission spéciale interruptions de
programmes
la couverture médiatique est
incontestablement exceptionnel
exceptionnel aussi les prises de
position des journaux américains
une trentaine d'entre eux appellent
aujourd'hui carrément à la démission du
président du jamais vu ça a commencé ce
week-end et puis on l'a entendu
aujourd'hui dans les journaux et je suis
surpris de voir que ces journaux
viennent de l'amérique profonde
des états comme l'iowa washington ou la
géorgie c'est surprenant parce que ce
n'est pas ce type de journaux qui
pendant le scandale du watergate avait
appelé à une démission rapide du
président nixon
la presse américaine est aujourd'hui
loin de penser qu'elle a trop médiatiser
la sphère clinton ces derniers jours
elle s'est même au contraire montrer de
plus en plus sévères envers un président
jugé irresponsable
usa today est l'un de ces nombreux
journaux qui demande aujourd'hui la
démission de bill clinton
ce journal très populaire diffusé
nationalement à un million et demi
d'exemplaires
il faut donc maintenant savoir si ces
prises de position de la presse vont
influencer l'opinion publique américaine
en irak le parlement a voté l'arrêt de
toute coopération elle était avec les
expert en désarmement de l'eau ils les
irakiens veulent obtenir du conseil de
sécurité la reprise de l'examen régulier
des sanctions
à bagdad pour l'instant l'embargo décidé
par l'onu est sans limite de temps en
allemagne le chancelier helmut kohl
estime que sa coalition gouvernementale
a toutes les chances de remporter les
prochaines élections générales du 27
septembre proches monsieur cole se sent
rassuré au lendemain de la victoire des
chrétiens démocrates en bavière il
convient cependant de se rappeler que
dans l'allemagne fédérale le lendemain
maroc connaît une situation politique
très particulière pas nécessairement
transposable à l'ensemble de l'état
allemand reportage de notre
correspondant permanent olivier werner
avec raph kinghero faire des gestes de
réconfort après la défaite à waterloo
politique pour le spd dit certains
prennent attache huit chefs de file de
la gauche en bavière a proposé sa
démission
mais le coup est dur surtout pour
gerhard schröder qui a mené une campagne
intensive sur cette terre à droite
depuis toujours fair-play
il reconnaît la d7 el mout cole a sauté
sur l'occasion
cette victoire n'est pas la sienne mais
peu importe il la reprend sans complexe
à son compte
du grand art c'est le col victorieux des
années 90 qui refait surface
tout à coup la bavière affiche un bilan
presque insolent qui fait des envieux
la gauche avait tout à perdre et si avec
ses réformes sur la retraite les impôts
les emplois jeunes les bavarois ne
demandait rien surtout pas de changement
politique de grande envergure
tous les clignotants économiques sont au
vert il n'y a pas eu d'effet fraudeurs
parce que les bavarois vont bien le taux
de chômage est très bas les entreprises
embauchent et investissent énormément
d'argent
de plus le bavarois est conservateur
c'est sa nature les bavarois ont été
servis des meetings par dizaines mais
qui n'ont rien changé
la gauche a prêché dans le vide c'est un
premier avertissement pour gerhard
schröder qui va devoir porter comme un
fardeau
cette défaite pendant ces quinze
prochains jours les plus difficiles de
cette certaine
alors s'agit-il d'un tournant dans
l'opinion où le signal d'un vent mauvais
pour gerhard schröder pourtant toujours
donné vainqueur par tous les instituts
de sondage
helmut kohl estime aujourd'hui qu'il a
toutes les chances de conserver son
fauteuil dans le camp adverse
on pense évidemment exactement le
contraire en algérie de 48 heures après
l'annoncé par le président zeroual
d'élection présidentielle anticipée un
nouveau massacre de civils aient été
perpétrés à 150 km à l'ouest d'alger
dans la région d'aïn defla 27 villageois
ont été massacrés et puis quatre
attentats ont été commis samedi dimanche
notamment à constat en république
démocratique du congo des combats ont eu
lieu à kisangani dans le nord-est du
pays ainsi qu à goma dans l'est du congo
d'autre part la france a décidé l'envoi
d'une aide d'urgence c'est-à-dire 34
tonnes de fret chargé dans un avion
cargo à destination de kinshasa en
france à paris à la nef la mutuelle
nationale des étudiants de france les
élus et représentants syndicaux
demandent la désignation d'un
administrateur provisoire
l'actuel directeur général a confirmé
son intention de quitter ses fonctions à
la fin du mois la nef il faut le
rappeler compte 700 salariés et gère le
régime de sécurité sociale de 800 mille
étudiants les procédures judiciaires
sont en cours mettant en cause certains
dirigeants et leur gestion frauduleuse
de filiales en capte les vielles caroff
thierry curtet pierre laurent constant
dans moins de 15 jours olivier spithakis
aura quitté son bureau de directeur
général de la mnef une des missions déjà
annoncés pendant l'été et qu'il a
confirmé aujourd'hui au comité
d'entreprise de la mutuelle étudiante
depuis l'ouverture d'une information
judiciaire la semaine dernière les
syndicats voient en effet dans le départ
d'olivier spithakis le seul moyen d'en
finir avec le scandale
nous voulons qu'il part parce que
simplement aujourd'hui il fait l'objet
de tous les feux des médias
je crois vous en êtes les premiers
conscients et qu'à partir de là nous
pensons qu'il est bon pour la mnef qu'il
soit coupé l'entreprise car la justice
s'intéresse de près à la mnef et
particulièrement à ces contrats de
communication une ancienne employée
chargée des appels d'offres affirme
qu'il ya eu surfacturation licenciée
elle préfère garder l'anonymat
en réunion une quinzaine de cadres et là
le responsable de la branche le frédéric
nous a dit que la direction générale
refusé de commander à des prix
intéressants
elle préférait la société spin spim
c'est une filiale de la mnef et son
devis semble effectivement peu
compétitif exemple les 1000 enveloppes
sont facturés 188 francs à la mnef
d'autres entreprises proposer le même
produit à moins de 120 francs olivier
spithakis ne répondra pas sur ce point
ni sur l'article du parisien où l'ancien
employé par le 200 millions de francs
détournés chaque année seule réaction
un communiqué lu par la président de la
mutuelle nous tenons donc tous à la
disposition de la justice et j'ai
confiance en elle en ce qui concerne le
son problème pour démêler d'éventuelles
rumeurs les calomnies ou d'éventuelles
fautes pénales
parallèlement à l'information judiciaire
menée par deux juges d'instruction une
enquête préliminaire a été confiée aux
policiers de la brigade financière
et cette fois ce sont les filiales de la
mnef qui sont concernés selon l'employée
licenciée
certaines ont servi à d'étranges
opération jeu consiste à créer une
société avec quelque part un capital
très faible qui n'a aucun client la mnef
devient client apporte toute sa
puissance de frappe
le chiffre d'affaires commencent à
monter la mnef se débarrasse de ses
parts et doit les racheter deux ans plus
tard au plus haut prix fort alors que
certaines des entreprises visées par les
enquêtes sont connues pour leur lien
avec les socialistes
au ps on se dit aujourd'hui serein nous
nous avons dix
clairement que le parti socialiste
depuis 1990 les premières lois sur le
financement de la vie politique était
parfaitement en règle avec ses lois
offrant le franc à la publication de ses
comptes publication sur ses recettes
officiel n'avons rien à craindre de
cette affaire la ferme nef
deviendra-t-elle une affaire politico
financière
pour l'instant c'est surtout le problème
spithakis que la mutuelle tentent de
réguler le conseil national du patronat
français examiné aujourd'hui l'actuel
dispositif harpe à rp c'est à dire le
principe de départ en pré retraite
contre une embauche ce système mis en
place le 1er octobre 95 arrivera à
expiration 31 décembre prochain c'est un
système qui a concerné cent seize mille
postes de travail et consiste pour un
salarié qui a travaillé quarante ans à
partir en retraite tout en ouvrant une
embauche donc pour un point jeunes le
cnps souhaite actualiser système dont
certains ignorent l'existence même s'ils
en sont bénéficiaires
ainsi ce jeune employé de banque dans le
reportage de sébastien guibert et
valérie criton depuis six mois
tanguy savidan travail dans l'atmosphère
feutrée du siège de cette grande banque
française il a 23 ans et c'est son
premier contrat à durée indéterminée
j'ai terminé mon service militaire en
décembre deux mois et demi de chômage
une candidature spontanée à la générale
un entretien deux entretiens j'ai
commencé mi mars
à ce moment là on va parler de l'art et
je ne connais pas la signification de ce
sigle ar pe allocation de remplacement
pour l'emploi tanguy sans le savoir à
compenser dans l'effectif de la banque
le départ en préretraite d'un autre
salarié départ autorisé après 40 ans de
cotisations à l'assurance vieillesse
pour les salariés nés en 1938 39 ou 40
ce sont les assedic qui verse aux
préretraités 75 % de son salaire net
jusqu'à la retraite effective
l'employeur de son côté sans rien
débourser rajeuni ses effectifs
aujourd'hui le dispositif qui existe
nous permet d'anticiper
le recrutement d'une partie de la relève
dont nous aurons besoin d'eux pour faire
face à nos activités dans les dix
prochaines années
depuis sa création il ya trois ans
l'arpp a permis le départ de près de 116
me pré retraités des hommes surtout et
autant d'embûches des jeunes
principalement mellark coûte cher deux
cent mille francs par allocataire 25
milliards au total depuis 95 à la charge
de l'assurance chômage
denise legras a déjà traité 900 dossiers
harpe pour la banque
elle aussi a suffisamment cotisé en
décembre elle partira pourquoi j'ai fait
ce choix pour m'occuper des moines la
famille et puis permettre l'embauché
d'un jeune en contrepartie dans cette
entreprise les renégociations de la
engagé aujourd'hui entendre et évaluer
des critères d'allocation et promouvoir
davantage le système notamment vers les
petites entreprises
le secrétaire général de force ouvrière
marc blondel multiplient les critiques
contre le projet de réforme des
cotisations patronales de sécurité
sociale le projet de madame aubry pour
monsieur blondel ces allègements de
charges n'ont jamais créé d'emplois et
puis à radio monte-carlo rmc le
personnel a voté cet après midi à
l'unanimité une grève pour protester
contre le plan social la grève a pris
effet à 18 heures et ce plan social
prévoit 120 suppressions d'emplois sur
249 salariés actuels à rmc en camargue
les syndicats de riziculteurs viennent
de rencontrer le président de la région
monsieur michel vos allées souhaite
faire pression sur la communauté
européenne pour résoudre leur problème
de mévente pour la première fois leurs
stocks ne sont pas en totalité écoulés
chaque année 70 millions de tonnes de
riz sont produits en camargue
mais depuis une quinzaine d'années
l'offre de riz sur le marché s'est
largement diversifié et le riz
camarguais souvent deux fois plus élevé
que certains rien porter le prix de
série est très nombreux dans les étals
des supermarchés reportage jacques
cardoze et gérard galian basmati taille
du surinam plutôt exotique le rayon riz
de votre supermarché un exotisme qui
fait vendre sauf ici en camargue
et pour cause vous achetez ce riz c'est
mon cousin qui le fabrique
benzema mais vous préférez ce riz de
camargue est bon comme celui qui de
fabrique de tai-chi patricia famille de
la ligue marc canal vert alain giraud
n'est pas le cousin de madame est l'un
de ses confrères riziculteurs tous font
le même constat 30% de la production 97
n'a pas trouvé preneur 23 millions de
tonnes de riz camarguais rester au fond
de ses silos une perte estimée à 45
millions de francs
la faute au cours du riz européen deux
fois plus cher que le cours mondial plus
chère que dans les autres pays dans les
pays tiers donc l'europe mais des taxes
à l'importation et inversement elle est
ouverte chaque fois qu'elle exporte donc
s'il peut maintenir en équilibre dans
l'europe parce qu'en europe nous avons
des charges qu'ils sont nettement
supérieurs aux autres pays
donc c'est un système séoul et qui est
fait pour réguler
un équilibre qui a disparu il ya deux
ans à la suite de la suppression de ces
taxes les riziculteurs français n'avait
donc plus le choix il leur fallait
obtenir un label de qualité une sorte d'
aoc pour justifier un prix plus cher
mais de meilleure qualité
sans ce label on pense que le riz va
être noyé dans la masse des rieux
européenne pas de reconnaissance pas de
pas de mise en avant est finalement un
riz qui va être bradées au prix auprès
des marchés un label qualité qui vient
d'être accordé par l'union européenne
désormais seuls les producteurs
camarguais pourront afficher l'étiquette
riboud camargue
ce qui n'était pas toujours le cas
signature d'un accord entre la direction
du site de salin-de-giraud du groupe dès
samedi midi et les syndicats cgt cgc des
salariés selon cet accord il n'y aura
pas de licenciements dans le plan social
une réduction de temps de travail est
également prévu le personnel était en
grève depuis le 26 août dernier bloquant
le site de salin-de-giraud qui produit
800 mille tonnes de sel chaque année à
la bourse de paris les cotations de ce
lundi était à la hausse effaçant ainsi
les baisses de la semaine dernière pour
paris près de 4 % de mieux pour le cac
40 est à wall street à mi-journée
tendance à la hausse également à l'hôtel
matignon et en l'absence du ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur jean pierre
chevènement c'est le premier ministre
lionel jospin qui recevait cet après
midi le préfet de corse bernard bonnet
ainsi que le procureur général monsieur
bernard legras quelques jours après la
publication du rapport parlementaire sur
la corse cette réunion devrait se
renouveler à l'hôtel crillon tous les
quinze jours
chaque jour des migrants clandestins
mineurs à risque en france venus des
pays du maghreb notamment du maroc dans
ce pays des organisations non
gouvernementales tentent de mettre en
garde les jeunes marocains contre l'idée
d'un eldorado européen d'autant que les
conditions de traversée de la
méditerranée sont souvent désastreuse à
marseille ces jeunes clandestins sont
pris en charge par les éducateurs de
l'association des jeunes errants ses
éducateurs leur rappelle quelques règles
simples celle de la vie les lois en
vigueur d'un pays reportage amk insurgés
christian hutin jour après jour sur le
port de casablanca ou d'alger ils ont
repéré les bateaux et guetter les
équipages longtemps ils ont attendu et
puis une nuit ils ont quitté le pays
avec pour seul bagage le rêve d'un autre
monde
ils ont embarqué clandestinement pour la
france comme on joue sa vie voilà je
suis monté avec une corde
je me suis accroché j'ai grimper grimper
et après dans le bateau je me suis caché
dans un camion noir sous les roues du
camion mais je souhaitais rester trois
jours comme ça j'ai trouvé un bon
j'avais un mal être c'est pas mon
problème de manger le voyage a duré deux
parfois trois jours avec la
clandestinité est venu l'errance le rêve
est passé
un matin laventure les a conduits à la
porte de l'association jeunes errants en
vertu d'un accord avec la justice
française qui se doit de protéger les
mineurs et en attendant qu'un magistrat
décide de leur sort
ahmed l'un des éducateurs leur a offert
un lieu sûr pour abris une chambre
d'hôtel payée par l'association après il
reste à ahmed a fixé quelques règles de
bonne conduite
c'est quoi ce téléphone je sais pas
olivier un téléphone je sais pas ça
tombe sur ouette son bureau il y en aura
une explication lecture le chan appelant
à faire pour éviter les dérapages les
vols il faut être vigilant et répété que
tout n'est pas permis
après la loi de la rue la loi tout court
sous contrôle d'un juge des enfants
les garçons vont apprendre le respect et
peut-être commencer à bâtir un projet
que je voudrais c'est apprendre à lire
et puis faire un stage de cuisine comme
ça si je rentre chez moi au maroc je
rentre avec un métier trouver du travail
c'est pour cela qu'ils ont quitté leur
pays
et si les mirages demeure la rue elle
offre toutes les tentations ahmed et
dominique les éducateurs connaissent
bien ces dangers là eux qui sur tous les
tons cherche d'abord à protéger les
jeunes errants
non non non la taxe la taxe sandwich je
ne prends pas à minuit des quatre coins
de la richesse comme la police à minuit
la responsable a et tous les thés
mineurs mais les mineurs tout à peine
dormi je veux être à minuit dehors tu
restes dans la rue tu viens pas dans
l'association unique équipe et c'est
l'association
jusqu'où le responsable quand il en
parle est étrange comme il a parlé des
parents regarde dehors qu'est-ce qui a
tort les voleurs les toxicos les buteurs
ou non et c'est cette vie là c'est pas
là pour ça qui me met en colère c'est
que ça tient un fils maintien fils faut
être là au bon moment
faut forer à gervais faut être présent
quoi
pour la vue ça c'est quelque fois ça
s'est joué en 15 jours 15 jours soit
parce qu'on n'a pas été vigilant soit
parce que il ya des gens plus malin que
non plus fine que nous plus manipulateur
que nous qui met la main dessus qui les
mettent au boulot qui qui les utilisent
c'est un travail de longue haleine pour
expliquer permettre à chacun de
retrouver le fil de son histoire
othman comme tous les autres aura un
choix à faire il était bonne élève en
terminale au maroc à la mort de son père
il a décidé de partir pour aider sa
famille othman est en france depuis cinq
jours ils commencent à réaliser qu'il
n'y a pas des leurs ados très cher le
rêve complet comme ça j'arrive
c'est l'amérique tout et cadeaux ça
n'existe pas où tu n'existes pas
d'autorisation pour être en france c'est
pas évident devant une carte de travail
tu peux pas travailler
qu'est ce qui est important pour tours
pour toi maman ta famille qu'est ce que
c'est qui est important
tap la salle et nous s'il n'y a pas de
solution miracle
il y à cette idée qu'ils peuvent
accepter qu'un jour bientôt s'il le
choisissent ils seront des adultes
citoyens de leur pays debout
othman a décidé d'en finir avec les
rangs c'est d'accepter l'aide de
l'association pour reprendre ses études
au maroc
c'est à sa mère la première qu'il a
annoncé son retour au pays à paris
première journée pour les entretiens de
bichat ces entretiens qui se prolonge
pendant une semaine sont en fait une
session de formation permanente pour les
médecins généralistes à des premiers
thèmes abordés étaient aujourd'hui celui
du risque de la surconsommation de
médicaments chez les personnes âgées de
plus de 70 ans
en moyenne il faut savoir qu'un homme ou
une femme de plus de 70 ans placé sous
astreinte médical doit prendre cinq
types de médicaments par jour
les conséquences sont quelquefois très
grave reportage daniel flaysakier et
vincent bouffartigue cet après midi là
le docteur daerden est venu prendre des
nouvelles du jour zifar qui avait eu de
bien étranges visions c'était quoi ces
choses bizarres que vous vous les voyez
des gens le veranda la tonnelle des gens
que je connaissais pas que j'avais
jamais vu
qu'est ce qui faisait ses jambes bien
grimper sur des arbres je viens moment
déjà dit écoute je vois je vois des gens
que je connais pas mais qu'est ce qu'ils
font mais je me suis alors vous une
église a dit que j'étais folle puis gelé
je crois pas car les hallucinations
josefa était en fait liées aux effets
secondaires d'un antidépresseur
c'est un médicament qui étaient
prescrits dont on sait ça fait partie de
ces effets secondaires ce médicament
peut provoquer à lui seul une confusion
mais il est possible aussi que ces
effets secondaires se soient ajoutés à
ceux des médicaments qu'elle prenait
habituellement à partir de 70 ans 10 %
des hospitalisations sont liées à un
accident médicamenteux avec risque de
chutes et de fractures notamment produit
les plus souvent en cause du rhétiques
tranquillisants et somnifères
mais le danger vient aussi de produits
achetés sans ordonnance ou bien du
comprimé donnée par un proche à l'insu
du médecin
les médecins de famille sont d'ailleurs
confrontés quotidiennement aux
difficultés de la prescription chez les
personnes âgées
simone du bois à 89 ans elle a été
opérée du coeur mais elle souffre aussi
d'artérite lé père plus de douleur et
elle doit prendre beaucoup de
médicaments
pour le docteur clouzot il est
indispensable de sa tâche et surtout et
avant tout à traiter la maladie
principale on va traiter par priorité et
faire comprendre que que d'autres
pathologies ils vont devenir très
secondaire et les médicaments devenir
plus néfastes qu'avec un portait du
bénéfice il n'y a pas de médicament
anodin
les accidents médicamenteux sont
rarement anodin eux aussi mis en examen
à gap du directeur du centre ucpa
d'embrun l'organisateur de la soie la
sortie en raquettes en montagne près d
or dans les alpes ou pour laquelle onze
personnes dont neuf adolescents avaient
trouvé la mort c'était le 23 janvier
dernier monsieur le directeur du centre
a été mis en examen pour homicide
involontaire par imprudence et
négligence au large de la province
canadienne de la nouvelle écosse les
recherches entreprises après l'accident
de l'avion de la swissair qui assurait
la liaison new york genève ou 229
personnes ont trouvé la mort se sont
poursuivies la deuxième boîte noire a
été récupérée mais l'avion transportait
également on l'apprend aujourd'hui 50 kg
de billets de banque de kilos de diamant
et un tableau de picasso au nord-est de
la belgique et dans le sud des pays-bas
des pluies diluviennes sont tombées au
cours de la nuit dernière pas de
victimes mais de nombreux villages
totalement inondée on s'attend encore à
des crues importantes commentaires
matthew g
cette vache reste imperturbable mais a
bien remarqué que ces temps ci en
plaindre les trains ont du retard
les pluies diluviennes oblige les
conducteurs de locomotive à naviguer à
vue et tout le nord de la belgique se
retrouve paralysée dans les villages les
voitures se transforme en sous marin de
fortune et les pompiers débordés
d'appels durant la nuit multiplie les
interventions là pour qu'on paie des
cadres non d ici pour organiser les
secours
peu de gros dégâts mais cette famille a
eu tout juste le temps de s'enfuir avant
de voir les fondations de sa maison
emportée et la protection civile nous a
dit qu'il fallait évacuer la maison et
puis ça c'était cool et une partie de la
saison c'est exprès que nous étions nous
étions en face mais évidemment nous
sommes venus voir régulièrement ce qui
se passait la nouvelle vague de pluies
et de vents annoncés ne devrait pas
permettre une décrue rapide
les pays bas également les pieds dans
l'eau ont déclenché un plan d'urgence
craignant de voir plusieurs rivières
déborder pompiers et habitants aménage
les digues à l'aide de sacs de sable en
italie les deux champions du monde de
football heure française joueur de la
juventus de turin zinedine zidane et
didier deschamps était entendu par le
procureur de la république de turin ce
magistrat instruit des affaires de
dopage dans le foot italien zidane
n'aurait surtout par les usages de la
créatine c'est un produit dopant
interdite en france
hier dans stade 2 dans ces dossiers
reconnaissait lui aussi l' usage au
demeurant légale en italie de créatine
et puis anthony cette nuit pour la
finale de l'us open à new york dans le
stade de flushing meadow le stade arthur
ashe
deux australiens se sont disputé la
victoire et c'est finalement patrick
rafter qui l'emportait sur mark
philippoussis 6-3 3-6 6-2 6-0 pour la
fille dit aussi patrick rafter est
désormais numéro deux mondial derrière
pete sampras
après quelques jours de rentrée scolaire
un constat la mode vestimentaire des
jeunes principalement des garçons à
partir de 12 ans se caractérise par des
pantalons larges très large il faut
savoir que 90 % des 15 17 ans achète un
jean parents qu'un tiers d'entre eux
paient moins de 200 francs pour cela et
qu'ils le font surtout seul ou avec des
copains restent alors aux parents la
surprise de l'achat enquête sophie mais
elle est franck vaillant
c'est bien hip hop deux influences
majeures au pays de la mode du nord pas
question de les mélanger chacun
revendique ces tribus si t'es pas dans
le coup c'est même pas la peine
d'essayer de faire partie de la bande
mais je regarde avoir commandé à billets
avant quoi alors si l'amérique super
ringard
tu ne parlera pas ouais à s'attacher à
la mode c'est séclier chine ce qui est
de l'absolu c'est bon pour les gamins
savent de plus en plus font ce qu'ils
veulent pas question de les embobiner
avec la mauvaise couleur ou la coupe de
l'année dernière des douze ans les
parents n'ont même presque plus leur mot
à dire
la norme telle extra extra large si mal
vu par les ados quoi je sais que dans ma
famille tout le monde me voit avec l'iso
a été tout le temps avec tellement mal à
quitter gilbert ce qu'on fait si on fait
du skate s'habille en skater s'ils
voulaient vraiment je suivrai de skate
mans ouais mais qu'on a fait
qu est ce qu est la panoplie c'est le
grand sweet si possible à capuche et
surtout surtout login quatre fois trop
grand
sortez sur la pointe des ans pas grand
chose pour le confort presque tout pour
la frime
côté hip hop on préfère les grands du
sport nike adidas fils à l'indispensable
les matières 100% politique pour que ça
brille et que ça flashe alain miran et
styliste son marché de prédilection
l'équipe comme il les appelle un univers
dont il a sondé tous les codes analyser
toutes les influences d'observation sont
essentiellement dans la rue ce jeu
faut se promener il faut lire et écouter
il faut regarder ce qu'ils ressentent ce
que eux regardent et être présent leur a
en gros son
césar production son atelier ados pas du
sentier parisien une dizaine de
collaborateurs très jeune pour autant de
marques destinées aux 12 ans et pousse
ici je travaille avec un an et demi il
avance en ce moment ils planchent sur
l'an 2000 et c'est nouveau chapitre
d'une même histoire avec d'infimes
détails qui devraient faire toute la
différence
la difficulté oui c'est de céder sur le
fond de pouls du marché pour sortir les
bons produits au bon moment ce qui
compte à la fin ce n'est pas sale estime
c'est le bon produit le nôtre le plus
juste possible dans la bonne couleur
avec le bonnet village et le marché bute
les adolescents aujourd'hui dépense près
de 30% de leur argent de poche en
vêtements parce qu'à cet âge-là au lycée
bourg vois tu le paraître
ça compte déjà cinéma sorti mercredi
prochain d'un film énorme godzilla ou
l'histoire déjà très souvent traités
depuis quarante ans d'un lézard mutants
issues d'essais nucléaires c'est
l'équipe du film independence day
conduite par le hollandais metteur en
scène roland emmerich qui a réalisé ce
godzilla où l'on retrouve jean reno
frais explications et appréciations de
pascal deschamps et luc bachofen
godzilla ou quand le réalisateur neil
dépens d'andy des fait encore plus fort
plus spectaculaires dit la pub
vous voilà prévenus pour battre des
records on a ressorti un monstre l'est
dans les années 50 au japon un lézard
mutants nourrit cette fois aux
radiations nucléaires des essais
français dans le pacifique comme
godzilla nagent vite et bien
il finit par débarquer à new york marché
américain a oublié où il fait de gros
dégâts
et comme les français se sentent un peu
responsables il envoie un agent de la
dgse aider les américains incognito jean
reno a pris très au sérieux son rôle
d'ambassadeur c'est pourquoi les
chômeurs pour avoir l'air plus américain
semble
bon c'est moi qui parlerai d'accord les
essais nucléaires ont été faits par nous
et grâce à dieu sont finies donc c'est
pour ça aussi que j'ai fait ils sont
terminées et aussi j'allais dire pas
grâce à dieu malheureusement l'inde et
le pakistan vont faire que l'actualité
reste et que peut-être ce film peut
faire réfléchir de ce côté c'est pas un
film à message
on pourra annoncer à l'infini la somme
de dollars le nombre de mois et de petit
génie qu'il aura fallu pour donner vie à
ce godzilla mais cela n'enlèvera rien à
l'impression que le résultat ressemble
finalement plus un montagnes russes
qu'un film
et n'y crée un film comme celui-là doit
forcément comporter des effets spéciaux
des effets de qualité comme amine la
canalise les films de monstre des années
50 était conçu pour un public jeune pour
les effrayer et les amuser en même temps
il ne se prenait pas au sérieux
c'est oublier un peu vite que le
godzilla créé en 1954 avait permis au
cinéma japonais de parler des effets de
la bombe atomique en contournant la
censure
s'il laisse sur son passage des villes
s'enflamme c'est que godzilla symbolise
alors les destructions dont sort à peine
le japon
et si la caméra de inochi rwanda
s'attardent longuement entre deux scènes
de frayeur sur les victimes du monstre
les morts les blessés les orphelins
c'est qu'il voulait faire passer une
émotion
son cinéma est également pour divertir
nous rappelle le temps où godzilla
n'était pas une carapace vide où les
effets spéciaux n'était pas une fin en
soi
il était un piano noir c'est le titre
choisi par les éditions fayard pour les
mémoires interrompu qu'écrivait barbara
ce livre qui s'ouvre par cette phrase
plus jamais je ne rentrerai en france je
ne chanterai plus jamais et celui des
confidences de barbara sur sa vie et sa
passion commentaires geneviève moll
barbares a commencé ses mémoires pour
dire toute la souffrance et toutes les
joies de sa vie petite fille juive
cachée dans les villages de france
pendant la guerre son drame profond
n'est pas là il est dans le violent que
son père lui a fait subir lorsqu'elle
était enfant
un jour il s'est enfui sans laisser de
traces des années plus tard on lui
apprend qu'il est mourant à noble
sournoisement ce ciel de nantes
non mon coeur joindrait au chemin qui
longe la mer à l'ombre du jardin de pied
je les couche fait deux sous les roses
je crois en quatre ans il lui il repose
en paix mon fait cette blessure l'a elle
ne peut la refermer mais ils étaient
fixes l'assaut elle veut chanter elle se
veut debout droite noire fantasque sur
scène il lui faudra des années de bel
air pour imposer sa voix ses choix ses
exigences dès 2010 bell est sur une
phase est vrai que je suis parfaitement
heureuse là et que c'est là que je vis
vraiment une affaire
tu attends
envie d'un vrai
en
comme on l'a lu
vers le point
moment
après avoir chanté les autres elle écrit
ses propres chansons elle dit on ne sait
pas d'où viennent les mots quand tu
chantes ils se marchent s'allongent se
distordre se consume des boules de ta
bouche à tes lèvres l'asie écrit-elle
l'amour la souffrance l'enfance meurtrie
le rêve voilà je voulais vous signaler
le premier prix du festival du film
médical s'était amiens pas si fou que ça
qui avaient été diffusés par savoir plus
santé en avril dernier sur france 2
réalisations de caroline glorion pour la
fin de ce journal je vous rappelle le
titre que nous avons développée au tout
début c'est-à-dire la tentative de coup
d'état en albanie à l'issue de la mort
d'un député d'opposition des rebelles se
sont emparés du parlement bâtiment du
parlement et de la télévision
le premier ministre ne veut pas
démissionner il me donne même un
ultimatum monsieur berisha l'ancien
président et à ses partisans pour qu'ils
quittent le pays
quelques rendez-vous maintenant la météo
isabelle martinez et dans quelques
minutes 20h50 la kiné avec charlotte
kady 22h35 paul amar évoquera
l'euthanasie dans son émission d'un
monde à l'autre à zéro heure dix
florence duprat pour le dernier journal
ne manquez pas le premier numéro du
cercle présenté par philippe lefait
thème de cette première du cercle le
désirent à 7h50 demain à françoise
laborde dans les 4 vérités recevra
monsieur georges sarre à 13h carole
gaessler et rachid arhab à demain 20h
bonsoir merci